la patate plural becomes la patate this
patate are boiled so no bolita in aqua
water we wake them using la belong
chopped and then we will mix them with
la Farina in solid and llevaba so one
guava masculine and then there is
something really annoying because Laurel
it becomes feminine let water other
ingredients ill laughter let's milk
in format job gorgonzola our old friend
Claudio Delita
la passata the Pomodoro la Chipola sugar
becomes lip cheap or left
you'll say the no salary
look to Cairo this is Duke Cara a Quebec
T in cubes little cubes
ooh baby
and I
and it's very very treatable so it is a
masculine plural article I know it's
trials of her fingers ito taurah becomes
there is mystic Italian comes from Latin
so perfect then we make one sauce with
we will need we would also make it
tomato sauce then we have this time we
will make a special sweat we will use in
say that
yes you know we have you remember we
have two very nice herbs yes we wanna
try to write yeah yeah